I want to let our listeners know that
you and I have been friends for a long
time it's absolutely accurate uh you
would come on my show and bring me
absolute Delight you would make me laugh
like a school child I love the school
children giggle a lot yes they giggle I
was a little you would you would reduce
me to a little Bavarian school boy
chuckling as I as I licked my marzipan I
knew you would say maip pan I knew
you and I was so happy when you were on
the and then to when you come on the
podcast you just bring me you bring me
absolute Joy like I've just had a brisk
walk in my leather shorts in the Alps oh
that's like a like a lip like a lipon
iced tea poured over your eyebrows well
okay that's just stupid it yeah welcome
to me um welcome to you how have you
been first of all FL I did embrace you
the hallway and you are made of pure
mahogany you must work out constantly
lots of pledge being sprayed all over my
shoulders no no I didn't mean you're
being waxed down like mahogany I mean
you are uh Rock hard you're no no no I
didn't mean anything dirty or sexual I
know that you're still impotent but you
I'm saying your shoulders your lats your
pecs I just it was like hugging an armir
like an awkward Lego yes yes yes yes uh
Conan H I am bored have you heard of
boredom yes I have yeah yeah so when
this occurs I just take things that
weigh more than me and I put them up and
down and up and down up and down and up
and down yeah the gravity yes and so you
you do a lot of working out I know you
have a trainer we've talked about this
before trainer Paulo is's Italian I
don't understand him he doesn't
understand me it's a very confusing
United Nations well the important thing
is you and your Italian trainer yes uh
get along what we do and um is he really
responsible for you being in this shape
absolutely I'm an idiot Conan as you
have learned I don't know what to ingest
and what to outest I heard that you also
like bicycles I like bicycles yes yes
yes I like to look at them I don't like
to I've never gotten on one is this a a
fact no it's a lie I was making what we
in America call a joke I think you call
it
a so uh I uh no I like to ride a bicycle
I do yes great just like the queen song
yeah yes I like
to just like the queen song yes I like
to get on a bicycle and I like to ride
it uh a friend of mine a shout out to my
friend Brad told me no one's ever had a
bad day on a bicycle and it's right I'm
always happy when I'm riding a bicycle
what about the people that have been
inadvertently struck by trucks
oh yes he did say I remember Brad saying
this with the exception of those who've
been killed riding a bike he did say
that that's a small exception but other
than this Brad Pit it was Brad Pit
correct yeah I don't like to get it out
there that I ride regularly with Brad
Pit yes yes but I ride regularly with
Brad wow yes not just a couple of us a
couple of us triple A listers you've
heard of a
listers Leo DiCaprio uh your Conan
O'Brien uh your
um e
Plum well she was on the original Brady
Bunch oh wonderful I just said original
like there was been another one has
there been a reboot no there was not a
reboot it's the only thing they haven't
rebooted um no they made a movie they
yeah made a couple movies yeah anyway
what I'm saying is yes someone like me
who's in the highest highest highest
echelons Absolut of celebrity Hood
single digit IMDb yes I just when I
start to when I start to ride my bicycle
other uh triple a celebrity show up
alongside me it's like Forest Gump
except you're riding a bicycle and the
people following are also celebrities
yes thank you you're welcome that's a
very good image that's exactly what it's
right are you wearing a shirt that says
have a nice day um no I'm not no you you
took it too far that was far enough yeah
um what is your diet like because you're
one of the healthiest men I know this
morning what did you have I had some
chicken and then also had some mashy
potatoes and also why do you call them
mashy potatoes what do you what do you
name those we call them mashy Mash mashy
mush mushes well see it's more I would
say efficient as a German we just say
mashy potatoes as opposed to mashy mashy
mush mush potatoes okay I was I was uh
pulling your leg stop
[Music]
it down
boys uh no we just say mashed potatoes
here ah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah have
you heard of the song Mashed Potato by
The Wiggles um no I potato mashed potato
no my my children are grown so I haven't
listened to the Wiggles in a very adults
can also listen to The Wiggles there's
actually a warning on the label that
says no not for anyone over four I
follow you'll go into a blind rage oh
perfect just start hitting bicyclist um
you uh so you get up in the morning I
want to hear about your regimen oh I
wake up I ingest calories I move very
quickly I ingest more calories I think
about Conan O'Brien ww CBD what would
Conan O Brien do and then I do those
things okay so I know you've been a huge
fan of mine for a long time very large
fan I once wrote a song about you and
Andy called Kandy oh really I did you
did or you didn't I did okay yeah
um
yeah and uh how does that song Go can I
hear any of it I need to clear it with
what's it called CAP ass ass cap yeah
and then I will send it to you but you
wrote it yes but so I'll send it to you
can mail it we can play it right now
okay what did you think I thought it was
fantastic me as well that was that was
beautiful that's a good song it's like
that wardrobe a triple Banger yeah but
now we have
to to flula I think we have to pay money
I refuse money I don't work for really I
get paid in biscuits
biscuits little biscuits yeah have you
had Bojangles in North Carolina a chain
that sells very delicious Southern
biscuit okay it's just biscuit it's not
bisquit it's just biscuit there's a u
inside this Con yes I know but we call
it a silent u a u that has been bullied
into silence I will never be silent
okay so you get up in the morning you
eat I think it's chicken yes no bisquits
no bisquits do you eat you don't eat any
carbs who does that well I'll eat carbs
all the time I eat them sometimes but
when I have a photo shoot with a Paulo
maiti coming up then I cannot eat those
carbohydrates I see yes you know I have
to tell you uh you put out a calendar I
do year uh flua Borg's calendar and
they're available I believe online but
you always send me one and you always
find a way to be um I would say
shirtless for most months are exposed
even like December January February
shirtless extra hot yeah no no I can I
use the the nipples come out of the
calendar and I hang my shirts on them oh
you can also use them to squeeze lemons
yes and adjust your radio dial if if you
have some radio yes serious my point is
you send it you very proud of your body
are you not no why is it so loathing cuz
some people that have a body like yours
are very self-loathing listen you have a
delicious voice and so you use it for to
make dollars and to make many many
podcasts I have a body that someone gave
to me I have zero credit so I have to
use I have to utilize it I have to
prostitute myself okay um how is your
love life going FL it's non-existent I
once dated a whole note a techno whole
note a what a techno whole note note
whole notes are four beats of music you
dated four beats of Music yes oh by the
way I will send you my flender my next
one if you want thank you very much I
yes I I I treasure them them I want to
hear more about this whole note yeah
yeah yeah thank you Mr gorley this is
this is a you have that's exactly you
always get me off track but Matt's here
to say wait a minute let's Double Down
return to the it's go Gorly oh why I
know there's a u in there yeah why is
that you once again it would be go
go you got go for it yeah Matthew I'll
take it okay great Matias G Mattias G
Matias yes on the ones and twos yeah so
you dated a whole note yes explain how
that works uh we uh established a
romantic connection and then we lasted
for four measures and then I
said and then I moved
on what note was it oh I see what you're
saying yes an E flat yeah yeah yeah
third position on the trombone Tre yes I
could have warned you against an excuse
me yeah so uh okay you are a monastic uh
you you are a celibate you are not I'm
Heloise not Abal Lord correct yes
okay so what do you do for fun after
your workout what do you do what does
fuor do I like to do clim tuug which are
push-ups and then also like to make
jogging have you ever made joging listen
I just said after your workout after
your workout you do push-ups and jogging
that's not after your workout oh you
have never followed David ggens on
Instagram stay hard Conan oh okay so you
do even after your workout you do more
exercise do minor workouts yes okay yes
what do you do when you're not working
out that's I guess the right question Oh
I like to sleep also like to uh look at
the sky and also at other items in the
world okay so looking at Sky have you
noticed anything about the sky recently
contains clouds on occasion and other on
times other occasions has no clouds okay
yeahum nimus clouds writing this
down and I will send this to Scientific
American this is good to know Neil de
grass Tyson also Strat cumulus cumulon
nimbus also very nice Cloud Cirrus a
little too wavy for my taste okay uh so
you're a cloud critic as they say
sometimes yes okay and then you you
notice other objects what objects have
you been noticing lately I've noticed
your delicious smile and wonderful
haircut Conan well you know I I look a
lot of people are in love with my hair
yes um how do you style it do you wake
up and it is like this or is there a man
and or woman that arranges it no one
else does it I figured this out myself a
long time ago I use various oils and
resins plus a little bit of mayonnaise
oh and then I work it in there and then
I cook it in a little Kil that just
bakes my hair Helman for 40 minutes 4 Z
yes helmond or craft well I don't like
to name helmond thank you yeah sponsor
shout out no it's uh definitely helmet
is better obiously hel you really want
whole eggs in there uh but then I get
this delicious pastry on top of my head
it seems to give people delight and so
it's a small price for me to pay to give
other people Joy it sounds like a large
price depending on the amounts of
mayonnaise and cant you purchase that's
true uh but you know I do it I also
think I may be do it to draw attention
away from parts of my body that maybe
I'm not thrilled with speak to me well
I'm just saying I have beady little rat
eyes that's incorrect look it is true
look look at me looking around beady
little rat eyes and I've got this I've
got this eye vein under my eye and then
I've got these thin lips like what
happened what's what happened to that
guy did he did he chew on a grenade to
save his regiment and his lips blew off
you oh yes episode two Band of Brothers
yes and so we hate to tell you what
happened to me your lips are gone no um
and so I think the hair is a way to draw
people away from my features that I'm
not as proud of very confusing you are a
beautiful man I love all of the items
you have described in a fully platonic
nonsexual way oh well maybe we can nudge
that over to
let's give it a
[Laughter]
try